blackpool victoria hospital in
lancashire one of the latest to declare
its situation critical staffing
pressures rising admissions and
relentless demand it never lets up for
the nhs
and a prime minister feeling the
pressure but sticking to plan b
we have a chance
to ride out this omicron wave without
shutting down our country once again
we can keep our schools and our
businesses open and we can find a way to
live with this virus as our nhs moves to
a war footing i will be recommending to
cabinet tomorrow that we continue with
plan b
more of the same but the science still
not yet fully clear what we don't know
and these are two things that we don't
know that are key we know exactly when
the peak's going to occur or how big the
peak's going to be and the second really
important thing
is that this has largely been an
infection amongst younger people up
until now and it's moving up the age
range now and as it moves up the age
range you would expect to see more
hospitalizations
and we don't know for sure how that's
going to manifest so many unknowns
except for one no new restrictions for
now the focus instead on keeping the
country and the nhs propped up we've
identified a hundred thousand critical
workers
in areas from food processing to
transport to our border force
and from the 10th of january we'll be
rolling out lateral flow testing for all
these workers available on every working
day
and alongside testing the continued
rollout of boosters how many doses will
you get
the pm and his health secretary hopeful
jabs in arms are the answer but they've
been here before a new year but with
very familiar problems this the second
january in a row that people
in there are trying to manage a very
unpredictable pandemic it's a tough
start to the year and it's made harder
still by the prime minister's own
political problems linked to those
parties in number 10.
for now mr johnson is gambling that he
can ride that omicron wave without
further restrictions but it's a big
gamble to take especially for a
politician already playing a weak hand
his political rival on the rise and on
the attack as we begin this new year
britain has entered a new phase
because just as the government has
revealed itself to be unworthy of your
trust
its incompetence is becoming plain it is
simply unacceptable two years best part
two years into a pandemic for the
government to say we haven't got enough
tests
lateral flow tests ought to be available
in sufficient quantity to deal with the
situation we now find ourselves in the
pm himself today said the coming weeks
will be challenging promising still to
take a balanced and proportionate
approach but it gets harder as the
pressure builds beth rigby sky news
westminster